do you mind sharing how much you were
getting paid how much you were making as
a truck driver in your time as a truck
driver yeah i started out at 25 cents a
mile
uh and then i got bumped up to 26 cents
a mile so um
we had a minimum
pay which was sort of a new
pay scheme that the industry had started
to introduce
to you know because there's there's lots
of unpaid work and time um and so we had
a minimum pay of 500 a week that you
would you would get if you didn't drive
enough miles to exceed that um you get
paid in sort of
so you get paid when you turn the bills
in which are which is the paperwork that
goes with the load
so you know you have to get that back to
your company and then that's how they
build a customer and so you might get a
bunch of those bills that kind of bunch
up in one week so you know i might get a
paycheck for you know twelve hundred
dollars and i mean i was a poor graduate
student so this was real real money to
me um and so i i had a sort of natural
incentive to you know earn a lot
or to maximize my pay
some weeks were that minimum 500 very
few
and then some i'd get 1200 1300 bucks um
pay has gone up
you know typical drivers now starting in
the 30s you know in the kind of job that
i was in uh 30s you know cents per mile
30 to 35.
so can we can we try to reverse engineer
that math how that maps the actual hours
so there's the hours connected to
driving are so
widely dispersed as you said some of
them don't count as actual work some of
it does that's a very interesting
discussion that will then continue when
we start talking about autonomous
trucking
but uh you know you're saying all these
cents per mile kind of thing what
uh how does that map to like hourly
average hourly wage
yeah so i mean and this is kind of the
this is also an interesting technology
story in the end and it's the technology
story that didn't happen um so pay per
mile was you know invented by companies
when you couldn't surveil drivers you
know what they were doing right and you
wanted them to have some skin in the
game
and so you'd say you know here's the
load it's going from
you know for me i might start in you
know the northeast maybe in upstate new
york with a load of beer and say here's
this load of beer bring it to this
address in michigan we're going to pay
you by the mile right if i was being
paid by the hour i might just pull over
at the diner and have breakfast
so
you're paid by the mile
but increasingly
over time
the
the typical driver is spending more and
more time doing non-driving tasks lots
of reasons for that one of which is
railroads captured a lot of freight that
goes long distances now another one is
traffic congest congestion um and the
other one is that drivers are pretty
cheap and they're they're almost always
the low people on the totem pole in some
segments
and so their time is used really
inefficiently
so i might go to that brewery to pick up
that load of bud light
and you know their dock staff may may be
busy
loading up five other trucks and they'll
say you know go over there and
sit and wait and we'll call you on the
cb when the doc's ready so you wait
there a couple hours
they bring you in you know you never
know what's happening in the truck
sometimes they're loading it with a
forklift maybe they're throwing 14
pallets on there full of kegs but
sometimes it'll take them hours you know
and you're sitting in that truck and
you're you're essentially unpaid
you know
then you pull out you've got control
over what you're gonna get paid based on
how you drive that load um and then on
the other end
you got a similar situation of kind of
waiting so so if that's the way truck
drivers are paid then there's a low
incentive for the optimization of the
supply chain to make them more efficient
right to uh to utilize truck labor more
efficiently
absolutely
and so that's the technology uh problem
that uh one of several technology
problems that could be addressed
um
i mean
what so what did uh
if we just linger on it what are we
talking about in terms of
uh dollars per hour
is it close to minimum wage is it you
know there's something you talk about
there was a
uh
a conception or a misconception
that uh truckers get paid a lot
for their work do they get paid a lot
for their work
some do
uh and i think that's
part of the complexity so you know what
interested me as an ethnographer about
this was you know i'm interested in the
kind of economic conceptions that people
have in their heads and and how they
lead to certain decisions in labor
markets you know why some people become
an entrepreneur and and other people
become a wage laborer or you know why
some people want to be doctors and other
people want to be truck drivers
that conception right is is getting
shaped in these labor markets as the
argument of of of the book
and
the fact that drivers can hear or
potential drivers can hear about these
you know workers who make a hundred
thousand dollars plus which which
happens regularly in the trucking
industry there are many truck drivers
who make more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year um you know is an
attraction but the industry's highly
segmented um and and so
the entry level segment and and we can
probably get into this but you know the
industry is dominated by
uh you know few dozen really large
companies that are self-insured and can
train new drivers so if you want those
good jobs you've got to have several
years
up until recently now the labor market's
becoming tighter but you had to have
several years of accident free
you know
perfectly clean record driving to get
into them
the other part of the segment you know
those drivers often don't make minimum
wage
but this leads to one of the sort of
central issues that has been in the
courts and in the legislature
um in some states
is you know what should truck drivers
get paid for right the industry you know
for the last 30 years or so has said
essentially it's the hours that they log
for safety reasons for the department of
transportation
right um
now since the drivers are paid by the
mile
they try to minimize those because those
hours are limited by the federal
government so the federal government
says you can't drive more than 60 hours
in a week as a long-haul truck driver
and so you want to drive as many miles
as you can in those 60 hours and so you
under report them
right
and so what happens is the companies say
well that guy you know he only said he
logged 45 hours of work that week or 50
hours of work that's all we have to pay
him minimum wage for
when in fact typical truck driver in
these in these jobs will work according
to most people would sort of define it
as like okay i'm at the customer
location i'm waiting to load i'm doing
some paperwork you know i'm inspecting
the truck i'm fueling it
um just waiting to you know get put in
the dock 80 to 90 hours would be sort of
a typical work week for one of these
these drivers um just when you look at
that does they don't make minimum wage
often times right just to be clear what
we're dancing around here is that
a little bit over a little bit under
minimum wage is nevertheless most
truck drivers seem to be making close to
minimum wage
like this is this
so like we maybe haven't made that clear
there's a there's a few that make quite
a bit of money but like you're
as an entry and for years you're
operating essentially
uh minimum wage and potentially far less
than minimum wage if you actually count
the number of hours
that are taken out of your life due to
your dedication to trucking
well if you count like the hours taken
out of your life um then you got to go
you know maybe a full 24.
that's right yeah from family from yeah
from the high quality of life parts of
your life
yeah and there's a whole nother set of
rules that the department of labor has
which basically say that a truck driver
who's dispatched away from home
for more than a day should get minimum
wage 24 hours
a day
and that could be a state minimum wage
but typically what it would work out to
for most drivers is that you know a
minimum the minimum wage for a truck
driver should be 50s or thousands you
know 55 60 000 should be the minimum
wage of a truck driver and you've
probably heard about the truck driver
shortage like if you know uh which i i
hope we can talk about um
if the minimum wage for truck drivers is
as it should be on the books at you know
around sixty thousand dollars we
wouldn't have a shortage truck drivers
oh wow
and to me 60 000 is not a lot of money
for this kind of job
because you're
this isn't
this is essentially two jobs
and two jobs where you don't get to
sleep with your
wife or see your kids
at night
that's 60 000 is a very little money for
that but you're saying if it was 60 000
you wouldn't even have the shortage if
that was the minimum if that was the
minimum and i think that's what now we
have drivers who start in the 30s
um wow but yeah and i mean so we're
talking two three jobs really when you
look at the total hours that people are
working it you know
they can work over a hundred if they're
a trainer you know um training other
truck drivers well over 100 hours a week
you